we're told this table shows equivalent
ratios to 24 to 40. fill in the missing
values and they write the ratio 24 to 40
right over here 24
24 when the numerator is 24 the
denominator is 40. so in that way you
can think of 24 over 40. but then they
want us to write equivalent ratios where
we have to fill in different blanks over
here in the denominator and here in the
numerator and there's a bunch of ways
that we could actually tackle this but
maybe the easiest is to start with the
ratio that they gave us where they gave
us both the numerator and the
denominator and then move from there so
for example if we look at this one right
over here the numerator is 12 it is half
of the 24. so the denominator is also
going to be half of the denominator here
it's going to be half of 40. so we could
stick a 20 right over there and then we
could go up here if you compare the 3 to
the 12 to go from 12 to 3 you have to
divide by 4. so in the numerator you're
dividing by 4 so the denominator you
also want to divide by 4. so 20 divided
by 4 is 5.
and then we have one more to fill in
this numerator right over here and we
see from the denominator we doubled the
denominator we went from 40 to 80 so we
would double the numerator as well and
so you would get 48. and what we just
did here is we wrote four equivalent
ratios the ratio of three to five or
three over five is the same thing as 12
to 20 is the same thing as 24 to 40 is
the same thing as 48 to 80. let's make
sure we got the right answer let's do a
couple more of these
the following table shows equivalent
fractions to 27 seventy-fifths so then
they wrote all of the different
equivalent fractions
this table shows ratios equivalent to
eighteen fifty-fifths
fair enough all right so these are all
equivalent to twenty-seven
seventy-fifths these are all equivalent
to eighteen fifty-fifths so all of these
which fraction is greater twenty-seven
seventy-fifths or eighteen fifty-fifths
so this is an interesting thing what we
wanna do because you know you look at
these two things and you're like well i
don't know their denominators are
different how do i compare them and the
best way that i can think of comparing
them is look at a point where you're
getting an equivalent fraction
and either the numerators are going to
be the same or the denominators are
going to be the same so let's see if
there's any situation here so you have
this situation
where we see 27 over 75 is 54 over 150
and over here we see that 1855 is 54 and
i this 54 jumped out at me because it's
the same numerator over 165 and that
makes the comparison much easier what is
smaller 54 over 150 or 54 over 165 well
if you have the same numerator having a
larger denominator will make the number
smaller so 54 over 165 is smaller than
54 over 150 which tells us that 18
over 55 is smaller than 27 over 75 so
let's see which of these so this is
saying that 27 over 75 is greater than
18 55 and that is absolutely right let's
do one more of these
lunara's friends are running a race each
of them runs at a constant speed
starting at time zero which of these
tables might show the distances one of
lunar's friends traveled over time
so they're running a race each of them
runs at a constant speed starting at
time zero so table
so table one
so distance run in meters so they're
running at a constant speed so the
really the ratio between
distance and time should be constant
throughout all of these possible tables
so here you have a ratio of three to two
if you if you triple the distance we're
tripling the time if you multiply the
distance by five we're multiplying the
time by five so table one seems
completely reasonable let's keep going
table two
eleven to four
and then twelve to five here it's just
incrementing by one but the ratios are
not the same eleven to four is not the
same thing as twelve to 5 so we're not
going to be able to this is not a
legitimate this right over here is not a
legitimate uh
of table
table three
so one to one then when you double the
distance we double the time when you
triple the distance when you tripled the
distance from one you didn't triple the
time so table three doesn't seem to make
sense either
table four so fourteen to ten
so that's the same thing as let's see
that's the same ratio as
if we were divided by two as seven to
five ratio
if we divide both of these by three this
is also a seven to five ratio and if you
divide both of these by seven this is
also a seven to five ratio so table 4
seems like a completely reasonable a
completely reasonable scenario and we
can check our answer and it is